okay
this is live stream by the way everybody
say no
so um
i'm gonna open the uh
hearing on the uh
um tax expenditure committee
and today we have with us
uh jeffrey beard and nicole levesque
said that right
from department education to talk to us
about where we are with the career and
technical education center credit
so if you want to both come up and
just push the red button there on the
microphone
and again with this we want to know
where we are you know how the program is
working and
and um
that's what this committee does so we
pass these laws and then we want to say
well
let's look back how we're doing and
and all that
okay
so i'm sure we fully funded you not like
the last one you heard last week
not two weeks not last week on april 1st
so thank you yeah
okay
so really
okay you have a handout um so
we've been doing this for a couple years
now um and do you need a recap of what
the bill is and everything why don't you
do that sure um so basically what we
have is uh tax credit for businesses
that are working with cte before you go
uh i i've asked representative burstein
to be a replacement today so okay okay
thank you
so we have a tax credit available for
businesses working with cte centers that
are donating time equipment um or money
so it's it's typically 50
tax credit for businesses that are
donating time like um if they take on a
student for an internship and they're
paying them they can re they can get a
credit for that student's time um the
the money that's paid to them and for
the supervisor working with them um if
they're donating they can get a hundred
percent tax credit um and they get fifty
percent tax credit for time put into
creating training programs first so
equipment is is a hundred percent
correct
time
time fifty
and money is 50
right and if they pay the stipend to the
student they would get 50 correct
um so that i mean general rundown is
really um geared towards working with
career and tech ed centers
and in the last couple years it has been
utilized
2020 we were able to get
forms back for about 89 000
and similar similarly for 2021 it was
about 87 000
and we're really hoping to see that
number increase as we hopefully come out
of covid and have more students engaging
in work-based learning
so um
so i guess the statute says not to
exceed 500 000. correct
right yep so we're not we're not close
to that no
all right we would like to be closer
right and there's a couple ways we can
get there one thing we've really uh
increased is a lot of outreach and
communication
both with the 29 regional career and
technical education centers and high
schools but also a large part of
nicole's role with the department of
education is to do direct outreach to
employers so nicole's spending a lot of
time with employers saying you can take
advantage of this tax credit some of the
pieces of equipment particularly for
advanced manufacturing which is one of
our main sectors in the state of new
hampshire some of that equipment can run
upwards of 150 200 000 for a piece of
equipment so we could actually get here
fairly quickly we just have to keep
getting the word out yeah yeah exactly
have those forms turned in so that we
can account for it so let's talk about
you mentioned advanced manufacturing
so
you're talking about 3d printing you're
talking about
robot arms uh yeah right yes
3d printing absolutely robot arms uh
cnc computer
computer operated
lathes mills
all those things that
the the thing that makes cte unique in
new hampshire
at the high school level is that the
kids are actually working on not on
simulated or sort of toy versions
they're working on the actual authentic
equipment used in industry all right and
so for that reason it comes at that
price tag that you see
the company down the road that's that's
buying a cnc router
this high school that needs a cnc router
at the same price tag right right
so
uh
yeah um the last couple years most of
our donation
forms excuse me have come in from
pinkerton academy and typically from
pinkerton academy out in the dairy
area
and most of them have been for more of
that time donation working with students
directly there have been some equipment
equipment donation forms as well but a
lot of it has been that time and money
component and i wish i had in front of
me a more accurate picture of
what the donations were exactly i don't
have that printed out just more the
numerical figures of what was donated
yeah they have a really really
great
he's done a podcast on this with senator
waters he's done
a lot of outreach to businesses at a
state level i've been doing the same
trying to educate work based learning
coordinators and directors at the
different career and tech ed centers
about this tax credit but also reaching
out to employers and saying if the
center is not bringing this up please
bring it up to them or me so that i can
help you get the credit
28 right jeff 29th 29 29 we just
approved the north point uh ct center in
colebrook uh new hampshire that's our
newest
center that brings it to my name sorry
how about the north point ct center
that's in colebrook uh new hampshire
and we have seen this year arms coming
in from different centers as well so
i've had a few come in from keene this
year
and definitely still the pinkerton
academy and the milford cte center
so
more questions at the moment
there was a slight dip uh one thing we
do see is that we're pretty steady with
about 9500 students annually that are
taking part in cte
um there have been
across the state some some slight uh
dips but they've bounced back the
enrollments are pretty robust for the
upcoming year so it'll probably be about
what we've seen that at 9 500.
one thing we do see is that although our
high school enrollments continue to tick
downward a little bit across the state
ct enrollments remain steady
so
this
let's clarify that then the the
there's 9 500 students that are active
with the cte program
and there's 21 29 locations
so what
are the locations
existing schools or what are the what
they're in existing schools so the cte
centers are regional uh programs that
are available to
students from sending high schools
within the region right but they're
housed within uh high schools so like
actually i think actually has one of
these yes yes
school technology is an expert right and
they do tend to be uh centered in uh
more heavily populated areas so those
students that are more rural have access
because they so so they they're um
so what happens is you're still a
student at let's say exeter high school
but you decide you want to be more
technical person you would take classes
through this
but other districts would send as well
because it's a regional thing 90 minutes
a day
so 90 90 minutes a day 20 minutes a day
and there's a really wide range of
programs some of our smaller centers
have
six programs uh many of our larger
centers uh that you'd see in in
manchester nashville concord have
upwards of 15 the most that we have i
think is
might be pinkerton which i believe has
21. and it would be the centers that
reach out to the businesses to say hey
yeah you know this is a real i mean to
me this is a great program i mean
but
because we need technique we need
in the work we need them surprise more
businesses haven't really jumped on this
because we need to create people who
know about this stuff
uh
locally continues to be that outreach
problem uh representative where uh the
centers are beginning to do a better job
about it um one thing nicole has done
that's been great is giving them a
little guidance to say it really has to
be multi-tiered if you don't have a work
based learning coordinator at the high
school
that it really
ought to be the career technical
education director and individual
teachers if you're in a a program that's
a more equipment-heavy program or if you
have a need to have some folks coming in
to work with your students or to have
the internships the teacher can make
that point of contact also every uh
every uh cte program in the state has a
program advisory committee uh typically
made up of between five and ten industry
uh employers
and during those uh
program advisory committee meetings
which typically take place twice a year
there's an opportunity for them to put
the word out again about the tax credit
i know you don't have the list with you
but it's something you can get back to
us on is how many
like last year how many businesses
participated yeah actually i can give
you how many businesses participated um
it was so last year it was five
different employers and 2020 was also
five different employers
we really would like that to be more and
we're definitely working on it
yeah i mean there's i mean there's a
real opportunity here it's huge yeah
absolutely
some of them are um there's we have like
l3 harris um lucas mediterranean cafe
new england document
fit new hampshire fisher cats is on here
there's a few bigger names um and then
some smaller businesses as well
yeah but like fish cat's not i envision
manufacturing for some reason yeah
as being where you where
you want to go because it's technical
i'm not sure what the fisher cats
well well we
yeah well there's an array of different
programs in the cte center so there's
culinary oh the culinary product we can
understand that yeah and there's um
okay got it
yeah
all right yeah so it really sounds like
and and
but this is and how long is the program
uh look on that how long has it been
around since 2019
yeah 19. so this is not that all right
there's nothing at all yeah
so
um
yeah it was 89 756.82
and do you have a number for 2020 yep it
was 87
435 and 5 cents
i hate to put you on the spot but
you said it's trending up this year
right now i wish i could say yes it's
honestly a little bit lower than i would
want it to be right now so i'm hoping
and what happens a lot of times is we
get a lot of donation forms closer to
the end of june so fingers crossed and
the deadline is june 30. june 30th
correct
is there a reporting requirement
yeah we do have to do a report to the
legislative legislation at the end of
the year
yeah
yeah it should be in by um let's see
october 1st is when we have to have that
report out too
yes well i'm reading that i'm reading
the statute here at the end
it says um
on october 1st of each year the
department of education shall report to
the speaker of the house
representatives the senate president
and the chairpersons of house and senate
ways of means yes
correct so we should technically be
getting this yeah and you should have it
um we we honestly had
we're a little bit confused on where to
send the report so they didn't
necessarily get right to you all but we
did resend them
when like january it was january january
we had a leadership change and some
things got lost okay so we have the
october and the yeah i mean the the two
right on me
yeah
if that's
uh
yes
you're welcome
okay so we have the exact numbers and
everything here yep
yeah yeah
and all who they are
as it stands now the program is
scheduled to be repealed
it said that but then it all we also saw
that it was maybe um
extended through 2026 and um
that's that's the newest wording we've
seen
well i see here
rsa 188 being repealed
219 effective
okay
right the repeals effective june 30th
right
it sounds like we got to hustle a little
bit here
it's going to be repealed before you
know it
so
okay
um
you you would think
so the as department of education i mean
uh i mean vocational
training is as important as oh yeah as
you know going uh college uh kind of
training
uh especially now with the job short you
know with the employee shortages it's
like
um
so i i guess the question is
i mean
you think you said you you
you had to
put up the heat a little bit and get
this
somehow get this more organized to get
the
to get the
businesses more involved i think one of
the things that i had said i wanted to
try was potentially reaching out to the
centers and asking if i could reach out
to their businesses directly
to see if i could help collect some of
that information and move it along a
little bit
yeah
no
well they what do they do they probably
reach out to businesses that are in a
general area right obviously because
there's travel issues the kids they
can't travel you know halfway across the
state
um
so and and then
they pretty well these
the the current 29 centers
are
kind of distributed across the state
pretty well they're very well
distributed they if you if you look at
uh south to north they are uh clustered
in population centers so there are more
centers in the southern part of the
state
uh but we're pretty well well
represented in the north country with
six
cte centers that are that are all up
right in the northern part
we also have a number of centers that
are located in vermont where some new
hampshire students take
cte in vermont
but we
the vermont centers don't qualify for
this uh
for the thing obviously
so of the 29 some of them are in vermont
uh the the 29 is new hampshire in new
hampshire oh but there's also a vermont
one okay yeah and to date we don't have
any vermont students attending in new
hampshire but that will change with the
cold work center coming on board oh okay
right over the border there yeah yeah
so
okay
we have tax credits to
encourage
giving behavior that wouldn't otherwise
occur i mean that's sort of the idea
there's a public
purpose that's served and
and
is served by
violet uh tax credits by these
and so the question here is uh
the participation rate has been pretty
low
so it was
well i guess two questions one has there
been and is there continuing to be gifts
coming from businesses that where the
businesses don't bother with the tax
credits
you know maybe that's happening i don't
know uh yeah
it is
i think that is likely happening i will
say though that the amount of paperwork
is not onerous it's not an additional
burden on the very straightforward
process so i don't i don't think that's
a barrier to participation i really
think probably it's really just
um not front of mind for a lot of the
folks that maybe are giving gifts
so again it just goes back to our
needing to double down on outreach and
making sure that nicole
continues to let employers know and that
also that the cte center is continuing
to let employers know what we really
don't want to happen is that
businesses that have been giving as a
routine thing this is what they do in
the community
um
learning that there's a tax credit
available oh boy
now that's a lower amount in our budget
net
of the tax credit and there's no no
change you know and same same
position we were at when we started out
the program except there's a little more
tax money involved
so do you have any sense about that i
mean
is there any shifting over in this same
level of giving
um not that i've heard of i've honestly
i've heard of centers still receiving
donations and
having students be able to do
internships and honestly been trying to
figure out why they're not using
this credit so that's something that
i've been
really trying to hunker down on and say
you know we have this why aren't we
seeing the forms come in
and you know offering my assistance in
any way possible to make sure we get
those forms and really we can't do much
without the paperwork
i think this is saying something dick to
us
it's a little bit it's saying that some
of these businesses are just happy to
have the
you know these students come in and even
donate
because they know that they need
because that for them they're hard they
can harvest them
when they graduate
to do the work uh you know
there's nothing like putting them in a
position and then they get to evaluate
them too
as to you know whether they you know
would cut it you know and uh when they
graduated
so it's so they just probably just find
it as a
you know something that's advantageous
to them without filling out the
paperwork and
and do all of that but
so i i don't know i don't know it's an
interesting question yeah
um
didn't the fisher cats just rebrand to
like the chicken tenders or something
chicken tenders
any
they idea with the fish again i don't
know but i can certainly probably figure
that out i just have to go back to the
center and ask
that is something that we're really
interested in the department of
education and expanding
internships as a part of work-based
learning and as part of that we're right
in the middle of developing some data
collection systems because right now we
don't have a way to collect valid
reliable data about what students do
after
cte that's something we really have a
strong interest in because we want to
make sure that a
these kids stay in new hampshire would
be are working in the area that they
studied
i think it's also a selling point to
grow the program yeah hey and we also
something kind of cool we have passed
back in december of 2021
by gnc a new program with a
reimbursement or a wage match for
employers that they could also you know
potentially use hand in hand with this
tax credit to to give them more
incentive to work with students as well
so it's exciting
so the did the students get
this is a random question do the
students get uh credits
for
[Music]
in some situations yes sometimes no it
depends on the school and if they're
offering
um credit for that experience um i want
to say most of the time they would be
getting some sort of credit
generally speaking of some sort of
elective credit yeah
so i the university of buffalo found me
i was when i went to school
10 years ago so i'm on the dean's
advisory council for the engineering
school
and experiential learning is
is up there
that they want you
know and
most of the programs do have
you know it's like a day or two a week
that
they would they would work with a local
business
and there's nobody exchanges hands the
business is happy to have them just like
we were talking about and but the kids
do get credits for that you know a
credit or whatever it is for that yeah
so
um
well i think too we shouldn't lose sight
of the the equipment donation which is
really a big part of this program and a
key part of this program because the the
equipment is
the the state of new hampshire receives
about six million dollars in federal
perkins money every year but that
federal perkins money
when all said and done ends up being
a little bit per center you know we have
29 centers there there's about five
million that goes out in distribution
the community college system and the
high schools and so at the end of the
day um some of our
less resourced centers claremont newport
some of our our centers in the north
country
are really receiving less than 100 000
in an annual perkins allocation if a
piece of advanced manufacturing
equipment costs 150 000 that's overall
allocation per year they can't spend
that money underneath my mind
well i mean these 3d printers aren't
cheap
or uh or auto lips
well it's a whole other area right they
do auto
well
auto mechanics are now auto
technicians yes literally
uh it's all electronic right i mean
so i said where's the dipstick in my car
there's no dipstick
[Laughter]
when i first bought my car that you know
the ones you have the setting that the
when you stop at a red light the engine
stops
i go that's that's got to be tough on
the starter what's starter we don't have
starters it's just a solenoid or some
kind of thing
i said wow bob i'll put a different
error
so
it is remarkable some of our centers
that offer within their auto tech
program multiple uh certifications from
different employers so you could have a
young person who decides to concentrate
on toyotas or someone else that decides
to concentrate on forwards and
be ready to work for that dealership
when they come out and the dealerships
are thrilled to get them yeah
yeah
you can't say toyota to a ford guy
so i had
one of my committees that buffalo we
have a guy that's was worked for four
for 30 years
someone brought up toyota
he flinched four or five yeah well
anyway
so okay um
let's just one more second looking at
what you gave us here and then
so is that
yeah
i will tell you for this year we already
have more businesses
that are use using the credit um but
right now we're definitely at less than
the 87. it's funny we have about 12
businesses utilizing it but for less
like smaller amounts of money i see yeah
yeah
and that's it
and all these are uh
um
benefiting pinkerton academy's programs
oh yeah yeah absolutely that's it wow
and this year we we have um
you know three
three cte centers which obviously is is
better than just pinkerton utilizing it
but we want to bump it up to you know
all the centers using it theoretically
because even if they you know each
center had one large
donation that would get us closer to
that 500 000
well
it just seems like
it's about promoting this more yeah um
i mean it's a good program
um i guess the only thing i'd i'd ask is
is there
any way we can find out
how many com companies are
donating
time
equipment
without asking for a tax credit
is that something we can ask the 29
centers to see if they have any sense of
that yeah i can certainly look into it
and see what information i can get back
right yeah
because that's a piece if it's like big
percentage that are doing that we you
know
say well
because right now i mean
time's out what did we say your timeout
is um
what i know
26. yeah
yeah so
we're approaching 20 well 22. so yeah we
got we got to be careful with you guys
we got a ways to go yeah
well i think uh
we're missing senator gaida
today and uh
we'll have a meeting in the fall is that
right that's what we're gonna do and um
we'll have a
report from
you
by the end of well
in july
um
so we'll have
another year
yeah
and um
you know if uh if you have additional
information about uh
that you could convey to us that
sort of addresses these this question of
a parent under participation
in the program
that would be really helpful sure
um
and i don't know what else you might
have pat
but that's
right
right so in that meeting we'll probably
have the two that could make that clear
about the two programs we didn't hear
about today
uh and then at that point we'd probably
have we're talking about our
recommendations
right at that point so yeah
so okay
somebody else yeah no i appreciate your
time thank you so yeah and then when you
sent those reports on it should go to i
would imagine it it would go to norm
major
from house
and it would go to guider actually
because he's chair of his chair of ways
and means in the uh senate did i send it
to the right people he did okay
no okay
yeah yeah oh yeah absolutely
see you now thank you
i didn't say you didn't have anything to
comment on right
administration oh there was a bit of
talk about the tax credits from the this
program just want to highlight
that
for the business profits tax purposes
the credits that's allowed
for
uh to be claimed shall not exceed 25 of
the tax due
uh for that particular taxpayer so make
sure that that's that's aware that
people are aware of that
yeah that is
trouble with that
yeah
right
maybe that's a limiting factor i don't
know
exceed 20 percent of tax due okay right
25 of the tax dude 25 tax too
okay
no
we can work backwards to kind of get a
sense of revenue you know
does that seem odorous i don't think so
what do you think
i'm i'm not sure because um this this
was in the bill when it was first
introduced so i'm sure uh during then
probably um
analysis was performed and that was the
the number that was decided okay yeah
i'm not seeing that 25
yes it's on the business profits tax rsa
so it's on the chapter 77-a
it's on uh rsa 77-8 colon 5.22
um
yeah and then
in the fall we're gonna
we're gonna hear about the um
that's my uh
the coast county job creation tax credit
and the
economic revitalization zone tax credit
that we were supposed to hear today but
we didn't
so
all right
and
and dick
okay thank you and i think i filled you
in on the uh the million dollars to make
it through
on the army the army million
i was at the committee meeting on uh it
was it was the premier conference it
wound up in
veterans affair bill
the senate finance put on a veteran's
fare bill so i briefed baldesaro
and then um
it was just it was after our meeting
they started to come in
so jess edwards came in i briefed him
briefly and he wasn't aware i was okay
so
so i went downstairs she went down here
and then i said you know i was heading
upstairs you know i better stop by and
see how they're doing
and they were they were a little
confused
because the senators
yeah
the senators the senators um
that were there
weren't aware of the background because
skyr wasn't there
then they asked lou to speak
like i don't know did grab blue or
whatever or
because he wasn't on the he wasn't on
the committee conference
and then when i got in there i could see
that there was some confusion so i
raised my hand and they let me speak and
then after that it kind of broke the log
jam
but
yeah so million dollars
um
and it'll be on the floor but i i don't
think that'll be a problem um
then i just so you know i dropped a note
to um
to tui from the army and to key wallace
to tell him that
assuming everything goes well on
thursday there should be a million
dollars there uh and if the government
signs i'm sure to sign it but
um just so they know that we we did act
we did follow up
you know so just so you know
all right so i think we are adjourned
right thanks for coming in both of you
so that one of these journeys did for
you what a nice sunny day
yeah no it was it was
you got to figure it out
a lot of businesses that are helping out
right right
they see it as beneficial
in some respects in many respects i'm
sure to their businesses and to their
uh
to their good will right
so to me where the disconnect was when
they said there were 9 500 students so
wow
i think there would be a lot more
businesses that would be you know
but
so anyway
so
yeah and that was always good to hear
from you let's just see how these things
are doing
and i didn't realize it was 19 it's only
three years old you know
yeah yeah that's a good point
yeah those were right those were covered
years too that we were looking at
so maybe the next report will be a
little better but
see
so jennifer and thank you for helping
set all these things up
do you remember who the sponsor was of
the original
thanks for coming in you're welcome
all right thank you thank you jen
oh we have an ice cream social on
thursday
i guess we're not having hot dog day huh
i thought they were going to do it but i
guess not this is the last
you